[Music]
comebacks in cs go
aren't easy from the pressure of playing
on the biggest stages to the tilt
from losing round after round any
comeback at all
is incredibly impressive so today we
wanted to honor the most
unbelievable come from behind wins cs go
has ever seen
but before we get into that i want to
remind you guys to subscribe to the
channel if you haven't done so already
and that way you'll never miss a video
just like this one and with that
let's get into the top 10 impossible cs
go comebacks
look there's only one comeback that
could possibly kick
off this list the olaf boost oh he's
here
he sees them down there straight
headshot they have no idea
smith's looking confused and dazed and
it's going to be a follow-up
shut off you've got to be kidding me
take the kiwishima as well
you've seen it a million times but for
good reason in map three of the
dreamhack winter 2014 major
quarter-finals
fnatic were down 13-3 with no hope in
the world of mounting a comeback
but of course that's when meister made
history and they they still are not sure
they're just getting
fired they're going down now in case you
haven't heard us explain this one before
olaf meister got a boost up into a
specific spot on the map where he could
see his opponents
but they couldn't see him giving him
free headshots
every round the boost allowed fnatic to
take the map all the way
back eventually winning 16-13
they make their way to the semis of
another major tournament here
pronounced with a final kill 16
13. of course at the time many people
were pretty frustrated
and upset by the strap because it wasn't
fair against llc it was a dirty trick
in my opinion that that specific boost
was game changing enough
that it definitely needs to be
reconsidered it definitely can't just go
you know unquestioned the result was
eventually overturned
giving ldlc the series ldlc
also went on to win the entire
tournament which might make this an
incredible comeback from
both teams if we're being honest
taking the number nine spot on our list
is a sweet comeback against the greatest
cs go roster of
all time on the catwalk area my goodness
nothing can be done and the renegades
have upset astralis in map one of the
series at the iem katowice
2019 major renegades were facing down an
astralis that
seemed unbeatable and i don't mean in
the metaphorical sense either
astralis were literally up 12 to 3 at
the half
well finding this one killing dupreeh
does go a long way however that timer
has ticked down and so has his health
points
even after switching sides things didn't
look great
renegades picked up two rounds but
astralis quickly extended their lead to
14-5 the map seemed unwinnable
but that is when renegades really went
off
but when there's augs alive like so jks
using it to his advantage
gratis faction there to support and
they're just gonna run right into the
crosshairs right
about now and i can tell you as it
stands
renegades have indeed done it they have
potentially shocked us all renegades
pushed the map all the way to overtime
where they ended up taking the dub
and it's now all come down to zip x ogg
in hand kitten hand
with the smoke on the catwalk area my
goodness
nothing can be done and the renegades
have
upset astralis in map one of the series
now they may have gone on to lose the
series but their resilience on mirage
made for a comeback for the ages
coming in at number eight is a comeback
so incredible
it needed four overtimes to happen at
the star series i-league season four
finals
faze clan was getting destroyed by team
liquid
and i don't mean like 15-5 destroyed
it was 12-0 actually almost uh
so eager to find the last player that he
almost got himself killed
yeah but the comeback began with an
incredible ace clutch from rain she
relocates into construction
see if rain can pick up round oh number
two there's a headshot midair
rain hiding in the corner this might be
perfect he's got the quad and there's
the ace
picking it up clutching the round and
finding round number two for phase
and then things got a little crazy
faze went on a tear winning 15
rounds and dropping just one to take the
score line
all the way to 15-13 then
liquid managed to squeeze out two wins
of their own before the map went to
quadruple
overtime 24 rounds later faze finally
closed
out turning what was almost a 16-0 loss
into a 28-26 victory
go straight on to mirage and that's a
great flashbang olive will take him down
and finally we put an end to inferno in
four overtimes with a scoreline of 28
to 26 faze clan what a crazy game
coming in at number seven is a truly
unbelievable comeback from
hell raisers during esl pro league
season four [ __ ] bialy's gonna try
and put this into overtime
but in all fairness the game should have
been done ages ago hell raisers
with an incredible comeback for what the
sixth time from a 12-3 half this year
that is just
unbelievable look you all know how this
kind of thing goes
when a game is 12-3 at the half it just
seems unwinnable
i actually made some mental notes there
the rounds uh horizons actually won
so it was the first gun round where vp
had two scouts and the famous
and then they won two tech nine rounds
after that they didn't actually win a
single like real gun round
but seemingly power razors didn't quite
understand that the game was over
they kept fighting after losing another
two rounds to go
14-4 they won 12 rounds
straight bondics gotten his teammate so
you're right potentially the time to do
so
he'll tank the nade and they're gonna
wrap around behind him so the chance to
save is getting limited and sticko just
nails a shot as simple as that this is
now 14-12
they would have hurt his pro were
looking vertice pooie
look there's no doubt virtus pro
definitely choked here
but the reason this comeback happened is
because hell raisers just
didn't give up they played smart and
stayed calm
under pressure thanks bialy finally gets
a trade but it's zero onto taz
and this is gonna happen it's all down
to bialy and virtus pro i imagine
they're probably not even talking to
each other at this point because things
are shocking bialy's going to try and
put this into overtime
but in all fairness the game should have
been done ages ago hell raisers
with an incredible comeback for what the
sixth time from a 12-3 half this year
that is just unbelievable
we've got a classic at our number six
spot because we're going all the way
back to
2013. nip versus very games at the esea
season 13 invite finals
can he do something special to keep them
in this game
no he can't it is probably the most
ridiculous comeback
i have seen in ages look back in 2013
nip were on top of the world they were
in the middle
of what would become an incredible 87
map win streak dominating the first year
of competitive cs go
but up against very games on nuke things
were looking
shaky behind enemy lines dies kid right
last player left last round two points
on the ninjas in pajamas
and he does go down very games at the
end of the half
with 13 points to the two points of the
ninjas and pajamas
staring down a 13-2 scoreline nip went
full
super saiyan and won the next 14 round
straight to win the map
freeberg now a one versus one freeberg
vs smith
smith is behind yellow he seems to think
so now now he knows it oh he's got a
nade that could be it
boom fryeburg takes out smith with a
nade
scream not looking in the right position
there
as a counter terrorist place forward oh
good ride what
crazy flips around there and takes out
that player
jumps out of the sky at him and he does
go down that's
game great job there by the ninjas in
pajamas good comebacks
you've seen the virtus throw already so
for our number five entry now we're
bringing you
the virtus plow perhaps they can finish
it right here right now
up against the odds james to finish the
job as only sphinx
missing his shot oh no way
that is a disaster vertus pro
put some respect on their name down 15-3
and they take it in ot you heard machine
say it vp were down 12 to 3 at the half
and then ants won three more to extend
their lead to 15-3
ants were on match point but vp were not
going to go down without the fight
in fact they weren't going to go down at
all three versus four oh what a shot
sanji
takes spinx alongside the utility down
and out
doto does have a very fast flank but
it's been held by james
and there you have vertis pro that's
right they won
13 rounds in a row to push it to
overtime
where vp took it home with a final 19 to
17 scoreline
not so easy for ends now a second
perhaps they can finish it right here
right now
up against the odds james to finish the
job as only sphinx
missing his shot oh no way
and number four come back is a truly
inspiring story of perseverance
it's quantum bellator fires come back
against mouse esports in the 2018
boston major group stage trying to make
his way back out that bomb he can't
actually stop it from being defused
molina so
blue [ __ ] is already on it sunny he
can't stop this from happening
what an incredible story here the kill
comes through a cinderella story
of what can be accomplished when you do
not give up qbf went into the major as
underdogs but they managed to bring down
top teams on their way to the bracket
stage including this impressive comeback
against
mouse down 13-2 qbf needed something
big to get back in the game
for a quick one when i was thinking if
they lost their minds but no you're
right they don't want to give the 600
dollars
and take the money anyway they're gonna
get picked off at least one here they're
gonna have a quick flank as well there's
the kill from quick boom just gonna come
with the ladder any second oh he even
gets a leg on the follow-up pistol whips
chris j at range
and the off oh no just barely misses but
jim crow is dealing with it
the defense holds strong again and
mousesports is stopped one more time
qbf won five rounds lost one and then
took
nine more rounds in a row to win 16-14
and locking a spot in the bracket stage
qbf might not have won the major
but they proved that they deserved a
spot we can't actually stop it from
being defused molina's sort of blooming
is already on it sunny he can't stop
this from happening
what an incredible story here the kill
comes through a cinderella story
of what can be accomplished when you do
not give up
at number three we have a major winning
comeback from astralis
bomb has been picked up by the priest
they get the spray neal takes one and
houses there
and astral as they win the first major
championship
16-14 against fertile throw
unbelievable australis started off the
final map of the atlanta major grand
finals by losing
seven straight rounds to vp after that
they managed to pick up a few rounds
here and there
but vp were just always a step ahead of
them it's just vertice pro continuing
four more rounds similar and they've got
it but astralis didn't panic
they held fast and fought back taking
the scoreline to 14-12
before earning their first major trophy
with four rounds in a row
can he find him in time neo just
crouching behind the angle and there's
one there's two
no saving it this is astralis's turf get
out
i'm gonna try and go for it but kevin
will take him down a quad kill here
important for vp need to get them out of
the hands of taz and pasha
nearly one they're sip with the kill can
they find pasha they will
caribou getting the kill finally pasha
coming in with a refract but he's down
the bomb has been picked up by dupreeh
they get the spray neal takes one and
houses there
and astronomers they win the first major
championship
16-14 against fluttershy
and runner-up is a play that needs no
introduction
coldzera's jumping off here he comes
once again the first base is a trend
he's going to hit the ground there is
cold
oh wow that's jumping double from cold
what is it going on right now how does
he do this
in map one of the columbus major
semi-finals
liquid and luminosity were pretty even
at the half
but liquid went on a tear on t side
going up to 59
it was match point and cold zero had to
do something
insane to keep his team in the game and
of course
you already know how this one goes here
he comes once again the first base is a
trend he's going to hit the ground
there's cold oh
wow that's jumping double cold what is
it going on right now
how does he do this call to save
luminosity with your play
unthinkable scenes there on the b
apartments they needed a huge play but
that was something i'm never gonna see
ever again the jumping off is a
statistical anomaly
the play shouldn't have worked the math
does not check out
it's a stupid play to even attempt but
it worked
and luminosity started a six-round
comeback to push the map to overtime
and eventually a win and that leaves
everything to hiko again
he is the man you want in this position
but one versus three
this is for everything this is for the
map right now nico making its way
around the smoke this family will spot
taco but that's it luminosity with a
comeback from 1510
an amazing play from cole with the awp
all the way back into overtime what's
even crazier though is that in map two
liquid were
15 to six before luminosity made another
comeback
and one in overtime again ethenics
jumping through the smoke and
adrenaline is a one versus four retake
with an awp and there it is cold is
going to take his head off
and luminosity will find themselves in
the grand finals
against navi and the top spot on our
list goes to a combination
clutch and comeback but one n a they're
first and
only major nothing else is going on he's
got to go back
stewie's on his own but look at the time
look at the time there's seven seconds
of blood and bomb
they're trying to build pyramids but
it's no more play
stewie's running around we're going to
overtime
in map three of the grand finals of the
boston major
c9 were down faze was in control of the
second half of inferno and things were
looking extremely difficult for c9
cloud9 are at the point of no return the
bomb is far too tech they cannot surely
they cannot win this they've got to run
away
they have to run away they've got all
the kills but he will win the round
it's match point face they weren't just
underdogs they were down
15 11 and needed something big
fortunately for c9 they started to
crumble
indeed guardian he whips the first shot
they start to march forwards
phase no this is their chance they can
steal it away from cloud9 the flick shot
miss guardian
in the most pivotal moment it has to be
kerrigan it has to be the leader
but it's rushed all the way in cloud
again
and then at 15 14 stewie did the
impossible to force over time
with just three bullets left
nothing else is going on he's got to go
back stewie's on his own but look at the
climb
look at the time there's seven seconds
of blood upon they're trying to build
pyramids
but there's no more play stewie's
walking around
we're going over time
n a fans know the rest of the story c9
took
it 22-19 in overtime completing a
comeback for the history books
that is the most insane way to win a
major
it could hardly have been more difficult
all right guys
that was our list which one of those was
your favorite did we miss
any comebacks out that should have gone
on the list let us know in the comments
thanks for watching and i'll see you all
in the next one
oh baby shroud 1v4